Welcome friends, whether you're out on a
walk,
running errands, or relaxing at home.
It's wonderful to connect with you.
Joining us today is Jody Brooks.
Jody is a midlife and burnout coach whose
own journey through severe anxiety,
depression, and suicidal thinking led him
to rebuild his life from the inside out.
and create the nine principles of
authentic living,
a practical framework helping people turn
crisis into connection
and sustainable well-being. Jodi,
welcome to Phoenix in Flame.
Well, thank you. I'm thrilled to be here.
I've been looking forward to this all
morning.
So I'm looking forward to a really good
chat.
This is going, because
we get real on Phoenix in Flame.
So we're going to just kind of jump right
in.
Listeners and viewers, I was chatting with
Jody earlier and I asked
his permission to bring up something that
he had messaged me when we were trying
to decide how to do the podcast.
And he gave me permission to share that he
had said his pile of
ash moment was sitting in a restroom
cubicle at the office.
crying so hard that he could barely
breathe,
realizing burnout was no longer a joke,
but a full body shutdown. Jodi,
that is an amazing description,
what people experience.
And I would really like to know,
let's just start with what that was like
for you in that moment
and in that experience of burnout when
you're realizing this is real.
What is going on right now?
think when you say this is real,
that's probably the best description
because that in that moment I was like,
this isn't just a thing. This is real.
This is full on now. And it
was a flood of emotions through my body
of,
kind of an accumulation of all of the
anxiety that overwhelm the...
pushing it to one side, the pretending it
wasn't real,
the, you know, just push through one more
day,
one more day. And, and I think what always
strikes me when I think back
to that day of some of the days that I'd
ever had,
that one was really insignificant.
It was not a hard meeting that I'd left.
I didn't have a hard afternoon.
It was just...
And maybe I sometimes wonder whether it
was that moment of calmness almost where
my body just went, now's the moment.
And I just remember just sitting there
thinking,
I actually can't go back.
And I think that's then when the tears
came is I just sat there and I was like,
I can't go back. can't go back.
And the canteen was full because it was
lunchtime.
And I knew that I was going to have to
leave,
go into the canteen, put a face on,
~ jazz hands, as I called it,
because a lot of my job involved jazz
hands.
A lot of the time of, you know,
I worked in education internationally for
a brand and went to our customers and did
presentations,
stood on stage, launch products.
And so all the time there was this.
veneer on of like, roll it out,
like that kind of thing. And so,
and I just was like, I can't even walk
through the canteen because
I was frightened of what I might say.
Like it was at that point where I was
like,
I'm actually not in control. I'm not in
control.
And whilst I was thinking all of these
things through,
I happened to like take some toilet tissue
and try and mop the mess.
that was on my face at this point.
And on the back of the cubicle door was a
poster that said,
do you need to speak to a mental health
first aider?
And it was the most sobering moment
because
and in that moment I was like,
I actually do. I'm not going to because I
don't trust anyone in this building right
now.
Got you.
And like, right where I'm sitting at this
moment in time,
you did this. You did this to me.
And I'm not about to tell you that you've
won or that I'm broken or say that
I can't cope. And so I actually got myself
together enough,
went back to the meeting room,
put my laptop away, walked to the car
park,
got in my car and somehow drove
the three hours home and did an awful lot
of thinking
in the car on the way. And, you know,
when I work with clients now, I talk about
this midlife crisis and it's
not a crisis, it's a calling and it's a
calling to connect.
And on that journey home, I think I
realized that
I had so
away of my route. I was not on my journey.
People call it alignment, but I was like,
it's like I'd hit this fork in the road
and gone off completely the wrong way.
And I'm a huge one for metaphor and
visualization.
And on the way home, as I was driving
home,
I just kept thinking, you need to come
home to you.
And I got home that evening, sent an
email,
said,
I'm not going to be in tomorrow and I
don't know when I'll be back.
And I took three weeks off and sat
quietly.
I mean, I was privileged in that I worked
for a huge global company.
We were able to take time off for things
like that without question.
It's the UK as well. So we have law here
that says you can't be questioned.
You can self-certificate for a week
without question.
So yeah, and
And that's it. And I got home that night
and just went to bed and was like,
tomorrow I'll make a plan. And then I got
up the next day and started
to make a plan.
Wow, wow. Jodi, that is such an
experience.
And I was following everything you were
saying and I know
my listeners were thinking, wow,
I know what that feels like. And as you
were,
as you talk about connection and I feel
like if all of us,
if we're honest, we're gonna, we can
connect with a lot of what you said.
And I'm sitting here, I already have like
three or four notes just
in that short period of time that
you
you were speaking.
What I'm wondering and want to get your
take on
is how we are full of,
mentioned the word anxiety, which is I
called a fear baby.
Fear is the father of anxiety.
And so it's like, we go through so much
fear of what if,
what if, what if, what if. And how many
people do you feel like are,
they feel like they're just one small
step from a breakdown. They're thinking is
this what is this when it's going
to happen? ~ They're walking along and
they've handled so many things.
They've absorbed so many big things,
crises and beat downs and criticisms and
all the things and then they go
to the copy machine and it's out of paper
and they're thinking
I can't handle it anymore. Is this the
thing that's gonna push me over
the edge from carrying around all of this
fear and absorbing all of these things?
What are your thoughts on that?
I think like, obviously, you know,
working with clients, the A word comes up
a lot of the time when you say like,
where are you now? How do you feel?
And, those things. I think people have a
desire or people follow a path where they
think they can eradicate anxiety.
And I say like, you need to stop that
straight off because anxiety is
a part of life. The problem is
you need to control your anxiety and it
not control you.
And there are ways that we can do that.
And I think you're right in that moment
when I said,
I can't do this. I mean, my coaching
practice is called authentic coaching
because I have a reputation for being
authentic.
And sometimes that can be dangerous.
so,
so. ~
I I always think in that moment,
I could like, I was like, if I go back in
there,
I might just be a bit too authentic.
Because that moment you're talking about
there is when,
when it breaks, when you don't have that
level of control,
when the anxiety overwhelms you,
because, you know, anxiety's purpose is to
keep us safe.
It's a fear detector. And it's to allow us
to go out in the world.
and understand risk, but it just gets a
little bit out of control.
You know, I talk a lot about our
subconscious when I'm working with clients
and,
I say, look, the problem for your
subconscious is it doesn't know whether
you're
looking at a saber tooth tiger or it's
just a Tuesday.
And, so, so,
so, so it does that an awful lot.
And so I think it's that thing about you
have to have a reality check in,
but the reality of it is, is, know,
when you get to that,
point, it's gone too far. And if you have
that moment,
like I did, then my advice is get out,
get out because what happens next won't be
pretty.
And I've dealt with clients who have
they've just like you
say the photocopier moment, the partner
that didn't boil the kettle for
the cup of tea, like all of those
Mm-hmm.
things, you know, and I just say like,
If you do one thing for yourself,
it's like come back from that.
kind of use a technique with clients all
the time called oxygen.
And it's like a Seth,
a stress safe word. And the whole part of
it is,
is that the first letter is observe.
The second one is exhale. And so,
you know, when people are in experiencing
extreme,
extreme stress, you know, that's what I
go.
through with clients and then the the why
is yield,
lean into it. Don't fight it because if
you try and fight anxiety,
it will go to war with you because it's so
sure that you are in trouble.
And if you think about, you know,
as well, it's people say it's irrational,
but it's not. It's rational because at
this point in time,
our body is being flooded with chemicals.
And, you know, if you go to war with
anxiety,
you'll start triggering adrenaline.
And if you trigger adrenaline,
you are on that roller coaster because
you're going to have to
do something with that adrenaline.
And so, you know, that, that yielding into
it
is about listening and yielding it and
understanding,
okay, I'm triggered. Like now,
where do I go from here? And then the next
one,
you know, is, ~ to ground.
And then I just say to people,
whilst you're yielding in it, you know,
it's just then ground, push your feet down
into the floor,
like reconnect. Cause at this point in
time,
you are, you probably have got adrenaline
and you probably start into like almost
float a little bit. It raises a heart
rate.
You're like, you know, kind of,
you know, essentially it's there because
it could be a saber tooth tiger.
So if you think about how your body would
have to be primed for a saber tooth tiger,
that's what it's doing right in that
moment.
And so, you know, and then the next
E is embrace is embrace it because it's
actually
the ultimate sign of your humanity.
In that moment, it's a sign of your
humanity
I love this and the acceptance that you're
talking about.
and yeah.
And
then we're gonna get back to the,
because I wanna spend some time talking
about those,
your principles, which are amazing.
I wanna wrap back around for a moment if I
could and hover over when
you were talking about walking into the
canteen and because I've heard this
before,
how hard it is for people to put on their
face.
How many of us are walking around and you
mentioned alignment that we,
also talked about kind of going down a
wrong path.
Life is complicated and it's confusing
sometimes.
And I'm wondering what your thoughts are
and what your experience
has been with yourself or with the clients
that because they have gotten
out of alignment in their life,
somehow along the way, somehow on their
journey,
they took a wrong step. And because of
that,
they find themselves having to put this
fake face on and how much energy that
takes out of us to act like we're okay
when we're not effin' okay.
Yeah, completely. I think the first thing
is when we talk about alignment
and in that moment, you can only be out of
alignment really,
if you know what alignment is.
And on that drive home,
I realized I didn't even know what
alignment was.
So it's no wonder I'd gone off route.
There's a great phrase that I love and use
all the time.
If you don't know where you're going,
any road will take you there.
that.
And
so I think it's this thing, we have this
huge bit.
And then I think that builds anxiety and
that builds a sense
of failing because people are like,
well, I'm not in alignment. And I love
that as a question,
clients come in for a session and I go,
okay, well, what's alignment?
Yeah
Yeah.
And I, and I talk about it as,
know, like, it's kind of almost a sign of
the modern world.
You know, we get in our car and we just
tap in the destination to the sat
nav and we presume it knows where we're
starting.
And we have the same approach to life.
And alignment is about knowing where
you're starting.
It's about setting the starting point in
your sat nav internally before
you can ever dream of a destination.
And so that then the anxiety part of it is
that,
you know, the one that I say to clients
all the time is,
well, imagine if I asked you to get on a
bus and you don't know where
the bus is going.
and you don't know how long you're going
to be on the bus.
You've just got to get on it and sit
there.
And most of them, I said, how are you
feeling?
They're like, well, I'd be pretty anxious.
And I'm like, but that's how you're
approaching life right now.
And that's where your anxiety is coming
from because the internal part
of you is screaming at you, but you keep
pushing
in this destination that you've set,
which who knows whose bus you're on.
And like, that's, I think,
this pivotal moment when we hit midlife,
which I love the fact that midlife now
starts at 35.
It makes me see much better about it.
~ I just tell all my clients,
don't panic. It starts at 35. So you're
No...
late to the party. ~
You're an overachiever.
That's it. So yeah overachiever
So, you know, but I say like if you think
about how life is,
know, when we're children We don't even
know we just get put on a
bus and someone drives us that's it and
we're going on the same bus
and it's that bus and then we hit teenage
and we start to maybe Not decide what
bus we're getting on but we get on a bus
with people that we think they look like
they're going somewhere fun and we get on
their bus and then
We kind of education career, twenties,
we kind of start to do a similar thing.
Like they look like they're going where I
might want to go.
And I think, you know, and then it can be
like,
I call it the marriage bus, the family
bus,
like all of these things we get on these
buses that are a destination that society
has prescribed for us, but they might not
necessarily be
the destination you're supposed to go to.
And they may be a part of your journey,
but they're not.
actually your destination. And so what
happens in midlife,
my true passion and belief working with
clients and myself is your inside goes,
we're not on the right bus. Like you need
to stop the bus,
you need to get off and you need to find
the right bus and get back on
it kind of thing. And I think that's that
whole bit of alignment of being
out of alignment. can only be in alignment
if you know what alignment is.
You know, as you're talking, I'm thinking
of two different types of buses.
I've had conversations
You
with lots of different people on podcasts
and I've I've guested on podcasts
and it's just an amazing way to connect
and hear other people's experiences.
And I'm thinking it's not necessarily what
I'm thinking about isn't about midlife
necessarily, cause I want to get back to
that cause that's hugely important.
But also along with that, I've,
I've heard conversations with ~ like Gen Z
generation that they're
on a bus and they don't know really where
it's going,
but they they have to get on a bus.
And they say, I cannot imagine being on
this bus for the next 20 or 30 years.
That's freaking me out. And so they don't
know how to align.
They don't know how to gauge what they're
doing.
And then also I've talked to people who
feel like they're on a bus where everyone
on the bus
is doing functioning better than them.
They feel like I got on, it's like I got
on the super high performer,
high achiever bus and I feel like I'm the
low man on the totem pole.
And then, you you think about how burnout,
it kind of plays out in these different
experiences of
how we're comparing ourselves.
Because you mentioned the word connection
and I think prior to connection
and a distortion of that sometimes is the
comparison.
of ourselves and what other people are
doing on that bus that we're on?
Are we aligned with what they're doing?
We're comparing ourselves to them.
What are your thoughts on that part of the
journey toward midlife?
I think, and when you mentioned younger
generations there,
like I think the reason that it's maybe,
it's a twofold thing for younger
generations.
I sometimes get asked, you know,
like, would you be 20 again?
And I say, I would be 20 again,
but not 20 now.
Mmm.
Like, okay. Because I can only imagine
what that.
experience must be and the speed at which
the world changes it's impossible to set
a destination and I feel like our younger
generations are growing up with this
you know like the film Speed they're on
the bus and it is going at speed and
think that there's some really lovely
things about our younger generation
as well that they are, I think,
going to question it, call it out and say
enough's enough.
Mm-hmm.
we're starting to see that in the not
prescribing,
the not adopting labels. And I think it's
a very subtle undertone through society
that speaks a bigger volume. But the huge
surgence about
you know, non-binary and these kinds of
things is this whole rejection
of all labels. It's not really about
masculine phenomenon.
It's actually about this rejection of,
I'm not getting in a box. I'm not getting
on a bus.
I'm not getting in a label. This is all
too much,
you know? And I say to people,
so just give them a break. Cause what you
think that is,
is a symptom of something much deeper.
It's a symptom of something much deeper in
our younger generations.
I empathize with this because I'm a Gen X
and for me.
And I think a lot of clients that come in
like mid forties,
fifties, gen X's, we grew
up with the destination of the bus being
very different to where we've arrived.
And so this sense of feeling lost in
midlife is,
well, I don't look like I'm in my fifties.
I don't feel like I'm in my fifties.
And all of my models I have for that.
are my aunts, my grandparents,
even my parents, slightly less than my
parents,
but I found a picture of an aunt the other
day and I just looked at it and I was
like,
hmm. And then I worked out that she could
only have been
50 maximum in this picture, but I would
have said 70
Wow.
because of that.
shift, change. And I say to people,
know, it's not, it's like 50 is almost the
new 30 these days,
comparative to my life.
Yes.
When I look at like that, I'm like 50 is
the new 30.
You know, like it started out in my 20s,
we were kind of maybe it was five years,
by my 30s, we were at 10, by my 40s,
we were at 20. And by my 50s,
We've had a 30 year shift in how life
looks.
And I say when anybody's harsh on younger
generations as they are,
know, when I used to deal with businesses
and they go in
and they're youngsters today, this,
that, and the other, I just go,
whoa, back up. Okay.
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
It's just like, first off, they're living
in a world that we created.
So if you don't like what you've created,
do something about the problem.
Secondly,
How do you feel about getting older right
now?
And then they go, well, it's hideous.
And I go, now imagine, okay, being 20
right now and having that feeling
with another 30 before they even get to
where you are.
And so I think there is this huge shift
change.
And I think like one of the principles is
empowerment.
And that's because
At point in my journey, I felt empowered
and realized that I actually
get to pick up the pen and write the next
chapter.
And that's what empowerment became was,
you know what, don't see this as doom and
gloom.
See this as actually, know what,
you've got a blank page. There are no
norms anymore,
Jodie. There's nothing that you're
expected to do because the expectations
have
all disappeared.
and as frightening as that void may seem,
you get
Mm-hmm.
to fill it however you choose.
Pick up the pen and write the next
chapter.
So that's a fabulous analogy. So what
would you recommend for someone
who is struggling with their midlife
calling?
You like to look at it that way.
And they're sitting there with a pen and a
blank sheet of paper freaking
out thinking, don't know, especially a Gen
X type person who we were kind
of told what to do. You you go to college,
you
you do this, you
do that. I we didn't, we didn't,
I mean,
Ahem.
didn't have the choices. And so now it's
kind of like,
okay, a blank piece of paper and a pen.
What recommendations, what encouragement,
suggestions would you have for someone who
is in that position in life that might
be listening now and they don't know what
to write?
Do they know that they did not end up in
life at this point of life where they
thought they would be and they might be
disappointed in themselves?
and they don't know really what to do and
just sitting there with the
pen and a blank piece of paper,
it feels extremely daunting. So what
suggestions would you have
for someone like that?
So I do an activity and my first piece of
advice
is actually start one thing and one thing
only and that
is to start stopping. Stopping what no
longer serves you.
If you don't know what to put on the page
because you don't know where
you want to go, start by identifying where
you don't want to
go because sometimes where you don't want
to be
has the clues for where you do want to be.
And so
like so.
I do an activity with people that's
literally called that.
Start stopping. I sometimes get them to
visualize a suitcase.
And I say, you if you were going on
holiday,
or let's just say, because I used to work
internationally.
So I used to literally, I mean,
think my busiest year, 52 flights in eight
months.
~
And so,
I mean, I don't
What the fuck?
know why. I don't know why I burn out.
I mean, it's a mystery to me.
No, ~
So, but so I say,
like, you I would and as you kind of as
well as been in education,
my trade was as I was a hairdresser,
a session stylist, a platform artist,
I did fashion work.
And so I would come back from a trip and I
would have a case and I would have
to unpack the case. you know, like for
instance,
I might've been in Dubai and you know,
like the next day I may be flying to like
most northerly Norway.
And, and I'd say like,
so I would have to open the case,
take out all of the things from Dubai
because I'm going to be pretty cold
in swimming trunks and a t-shirt in
Northern Norway.
in.
And so I say, you kind of have to do the
same thing with life.
So you've arrived here with this trunk
full of stuff and some of it
you just don't need. And if you're going
to put new stuff in,
you're going to have to take old stuff out
and you're going
I love that.
to have to start stopping the things that
no longer serve you.
And, know, my realization in that was
because those two weeks that followed that
Burnett.
That's exactly what I did. I was like,
okay, I don't know where I'm going to go,
but I definitely know where I don't want
to be.
So let's start with where I don't want to
be.
Because if I start writing a chapter that
doesn't have those things in
and I make sure it doesn't have those
things in,
then I'm pretty confident that destination
is going to be better than
the one that I'm currently on.
I love that. I'm a visual person too,
so I absolutely adore analogies.
And as I'm listening to you describe that,
of course, I'm known as the queen of
boundaries.
And so I'm thinking
you
to let go of things, to stop things that
no longer serve us,
it requires the agency to say no,
whether we are opting out of...
relationship that we've been in for
decades maybe,
but it's really sucking our emotional
energy out of us and not leaving
us with enough energy to do with what we
want to do.
Or maybe it's an event or some events that
we have signed up for that
we are contributing our time and our
energy to that just really don't serve
us when we do that analysis that you're
talking about.
I think, I mean, I also am a huge believer
in boundaries and,
and, but I always, you know, kind of the
second principle
is understanding after that moment of
awareness is understanding why and
In that is where your core values are and
sitting behind everything.
When you start to find the why and you
start to see the pattern behind it,
your core values will be in there
somewhere.
And
Mm-hmm.
that's your subconscious making those
decisions.
Well, no, cause you don't believe in that
blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. But if you
don't know what they are again,
alignment, you trigger things like guilt
and all of those things.
There's obviously a big journey from
understanding to integrity,
which is where boundaries kick in.
But, ~
That whole point there is, that by the
time I got to that and I
was really clear about what my boundaries
were,
I could actually really see why I'd found
the workplace really hard.
And I could see why relationships had gone
wrong.
I could see why I'd had conflict that I'd
had.
I could see why I'd put myself in
positions where I was able to be hurt.
I could see all of these things all of a
sudden really clearly,
because I could look at every situation
and go,
yeah.
That wasn't meeting your growth need yet.
That wasn't authentic yet. That was
injustice.
So I can navigate and still do to this
day,
you know, like that alignment piece now is
those five core values that I
can turn up every day. And I know what my
boundaries are because I think
the other thing about boundaries is people
see them as so final.
I always say to clients, look,
when you know,
what your values are. For some of them,
they will have a boundary that's here.
Some of them will have a boundary here,
and some of them will have a boundary
here.
Now, some of them will have a gate,
and there will be rules and conditions to
which you allow people through that
boundary, through that gate. So
Mm-hmm.
don't see them as finite, but they...
Somebody actually said this to me the
other day.
How do you say no so easily? And I go,
I just say, because I know that it doesn't
serve me already.
And if it doesn't serve me, this is how
you get to do stuff guilt free.
And it is a hard journey for people to get
their head around
it because obviously we're conditioned
about being selfish and all of those
things.
But if something doesn't truly serve you,
it can't serve the other person.
So in fact, if you continue to do that,
you're doing a disservice to the other
person because
Yes.
the relationship you're forming is not
authentic and you've already destined
it to fail. And so
Yes.
when I went back over my, you know,
in the like 18 month journey after burnout
and discovering the nine principles,
I went all the way back to my childhood
and you know,
these different things came up and I was
like,
yeah, that's why.
You know, that's why, because that's it.
was screaming at you kind of thing.
And so I think you,
I say it's like, you know, I was worried
this thing,
you're on a podcast, you know,
and you've done the journey and you,
know, like you make it sound like it's so
simple and it wasn't simple.
It's a lot of inner work and a lot of hard
work,
but I promise you that the destination
point of it is so worth
it because it prevents you.
from putting the wrong shit in your
suitcase from that point forward.
You won't have to unpack again because you
won't put it in there again.
I love this. That is amazing. our time is
up.
So I wanted to make sure that the
listeners and the viewers are able
to get access to you and learn more about
you and get access to,
your nine principles. So what I have is
AuthenticCoaching.me.
Is that the website?
Yep, that's it.
Perfect. Yeah, that's my website.
Everything's there. It's really easy.
There's a free to join community as well.
So you can jump in there and oxygen that I
mentioned and start stopping
are actually free resources that are
inside the community.
So they can jump on and download away and
message me.
I love that. Oh, Jodi, this
has been, I feel like we could probably
talk for another easily,
I
another 30 minutes, but I appreciate your
time and your willingness to come and
share your transparency,
your journey, your wisdom with Phoenix and
Flame listeners and viewers.
Jodi, thank you so, much.
No, thank you. mean that, you know,
my grandmother always said, if you find
something you love,
you'll never do a day's work. And this
episode has been a complete example of
that.
That is wonderful. I love being with you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Listeners, viewers, my gosh. I know you
have heard multiple things today from Jodi
that you're thinking, you know what?
I know a friend, I know a coworker,
I know a relative that absolutely needs to
hear what Jodi said on Phoenix in Flame.
Take this podcast episode, copy and paste
this link,
send it through text, send it through
email,
put it on your favorite social media
sites.
so we can grow our Phoenix and Flame
community and let people know
you are not alone. I hope your day is
going great.
I'm Dana on Phoenix and Flame.